more light that's what the inhabitants
of vegan Ella have always wanted in
winter for three months a year the
village is plunged into darkness and
cold many of the locals can't deal with
it
so they escaped to sunnier spots leaving
house is empty but there is some help
coming from above where the Sun shines
vegan Ella's deputy mayor Pierre Franco
me Dali who is actually a train driver
is committed to bringing light to the
village yet so we're heading for a rocky
promontory well above the village where
there's a mirror which will beam
sunlight straight on to the village
square it will take an hour to get to
the spot the mirror is in need of new
equipment and some repairs the sides of
the etre no valley are so steep that
cables or in the old days mules are the
only way of transporting heavy equipment
to the top a slow painstaking journey
that's not quite over yet Pere Franco
has to undertake the final metres on
foot and finally he makes it he's 1100
meters above the village which is hidden
deep in the valley and here's the mirror
measuring 5 by 8 meters in size
[Music]
the mayor fulfilled a lifelong dream
when he had it installed 10 years ago to
bring light to the dark Valley a real
technological challenge not a flashy Oni
the material reflects 95% of the
sunlight that's almost all the
luminosity but some of it gets lost
because of vapor and dust particles in
the air during the refraction after all
the light does have to travel another
kilometer to get to the village
yesterday by using after installing the
control box they have to check
everything is working the circuits and
hydraulic Pistons remain broken for two
years after a fire damaged the control
unit the mirror was left to its own
devices
the village remained in the dark
but now it's working again and beam
sunlight right into vegan Ella it even
illuminates roofs and facades and parts
of the village that have never captured
the Sun before such as the church's
northern side to the delight of the
villagers
[Music]
Giannino and his wife Romina looked
forward to this day for a long time
they're so glad to have light again
after two dark winters of course it's
not as powerful as the real Sun it's
just a mirror but we're happy about this
for sure the light warms my heart
something is happening that I could
never have imagined we have to celebrate
that fact that we've finally got Sun on
our Piazza in winter it's wonderful but
there's still some fine-tuning to be
done the solar cycle has been saved by
the computer which can communicate with
the mirror and make adjustments as
necessary the mirror moves like the Sun
but very slow and in the opposite
direction the sunlight is always
reflected into the church square but
even this is not enough for me Dali he
wants to bring sunlight to the darkest
corners of vegan Ella so that the
village comes back to life in winter to
the de Patsy we have to be a bit crazy
in a positive way to have new ideas and
visions it helps to break out of this
little world around you Tonto for now
there seems to be no reason why he will
not be able to realize his vision and
bring light to life to vegan Ella for
many winters to come
[Music]